disney is at it again you know i don't
really watch the superhero movies i
don't really watch disney but my
producers they're forcing me to watch
this trailer because apparently marvel
which is disney which is i don't know
they're all like the same company now
disney slash marvel has decided to make
the hulk
a chick because they must have looked
and they saw okay
when they took ghostbusters and and made
it the chick version of ghostbusters it
completely bombed and so they thought
okay all these movies that we just redo
but with girls
are terrible and and no one goes to see
them so you know what we should do we
should take the most masculine character
in the history of fantasy and turn the
character into a chick i i actually do
not believe that this is real i have to
assume that this is ironic or
like a late april fool's joke or
something but they're calling it
she-hulk
attorney
at law let's roll the trailer
being a superhero
is a trial by fire
who's gonna protect the world it's not
people like you
[Applause]
we'll pause it right there
at least she's kind of hot it feels
really hot in here is it hot in here you
know now what they've been trying to do
is take all the hot characters and make
them not hot because
being attractive is regressive and
reactionary and conservative and so you
see this all over the advertising now
lingerie models and is are just
officiously not physically attractive so
okay at least all i saw was the view of
this green monster from the back and she
looked
you know not not bad
i'm jennifer walters i'm a lawyer i have
great friends can we get some shots
please it's an emergency a demanding job
we just started a super human law
division and i want you to be the face
of it
and a frustrating family because we
didn't ask for this
but you still got to deal with it your
transformations are triggered by anger
and fear
those are like the baseline of any woman
just existing
oh
i feel like if i don't transform i'm
gonna die
yes yes yes
no
no
i just want to be a normal anonymous
lawyer can you tell us where she-hulk is
jen you're a story now girl you're
you'll like her crazy right now
you'll you'll like her when she's angry
you see because you you won't like the
man isn't that that's the line from the
hulk you won't like me when i'm angry
you wouldn't like me when i'm angry i
don't like you now and you won't because
he's a man and you won't like him but
you will like her because she's a girl
and girls are better at everything and
men are bad girls are good the thing
that girls are known for of course is
their physical strength right that's
what makes a girl a girl
we are told by feminism of course that
is not the case but that is what we are
told we are told that that women can
only have value if they just do all the
stuff guys do when when women do the
stuff that women traditionally and
naturally do like have babies nurture uh
be the hands that rocks the cradle is
the hand that rules the world you know
any of any of that that's worthless
that's terrible that's mocked and
derided so they just need to be they
just need to punch people that's what'll
give women value they need to do the
stuff that men don't do not as well
that's what the and then women will have
value and you'll like her
you go girl you'll like her when she's
angry all right
girl your ass looks crazy right now
that was sort of my first comment
you could be an avenger oh i'm not a
superhero
that is for billionaires and narcissists
and adult orphans for some reason
[Music]
is there anything more depressing than
dating in your 30s yeah this is the best
date i've had in a while oh should we
split some fries let's get those to go
so i guess the the one thing that's sort
of sexually accurate here
is that the
what the woman has done is basically
just shoot up a bunch of testosterone
she's basically gone trans that that's
what this show is about it is now
occurring to me the show is about a
transgender woman to man who just takes
a bunch of magic serum known as
testosterone and and seems to look more
masculine and then what you see in that
final scene is she's got a extremely
increased sex drive
usually it's been a while since i've
been on a date with a random woman but
usually on a first date it's not the
woman who who says hey buddy let's get
out of here let's go i'm going to pick
you up and take you home and throw you
on the bed right
that's not what happens
but the woman is trans because she's the
hulk so she's got all this
aggressive masculine testosterone
floating through her and so she gets
this increased sex drive which is what
happens by the way
i interviewed a gal who went on
testosterone because she thought she was
transgender and then got off of it and
she said one of the first things that
happened was she had a really increased
sex drive and then you you see here this
gal carries the guy and totally reverses
the roles and now the women are the man
and the men are i don't know what the
men are
i was hoping this was going to be
ironic
i was hoping that this was going to be a
kind of joke about i was hoping beyond
hope obviously this wasn't going to be
the case but if it were a joke about how
dumb the superhero genre has become and
how tedious and how it's always the same
movie if it were a joke about feminism
you know
we just need to take all the old normal
stuff and then replace the men with
women and that's going to be so much how
original all right give me my million
dollars here's my script i just crossed
out he and wrote she
if it were something like that if it
were a spoof if it were like deadpool
for instance
i could see it kind of working but of
course it's not that you heard that that
feminist line right at the very top
where
the the regular hulk says something
about how difficult things are going to
be and she says oh yeah that's every day
for a woman oh we're so put upon it's
just so hard being a woman gosh you men
have you you don't do anything hard you
don't other than just like work all the
time and go and fight wars and stuff and
just and die earlier because of how hard
you work and yeah it's your life is so
easy you just you're just like loafing
homer simpson sitting on the couch but
we gals you know we we bear the entire
burden of society and so you get that
kind of a line right off the top you
realize she's being earnest
this is an earnest
she-hulk the likelihood that i will
watch this
this superhero content is exactly the
same likelihood that i would watch any
other superhero content
so i guess it has that going for it
[Music]
[Music]
you